[Aplausos]
accidente o nacimiento esa fue la
pregunta de un señor remisero al verme a
subir a su auto nacimiento le respondí
y mientras me estaba acomodando en el
asiento del auto este hombre que no me
dejaba de mirar me dice que canchera que
estás
y si un año le dije
a lo que él me seguía mirando y me
pregunta vos crees en dios
lo miro y lo veo tan preocupado
tan afligido como diciéndome pobre chica
que le dije tranquilo yo estoy bien uno
puede tener un montón de problemas pero
justamente mi discapacidad no era lo que
en ese momento me estaba molestando
sufría más por las desilusiones amorosas
que por otra cosa
yo tengo una discapacidad no estoy
enferma no necesito pedirle a dios ni a
los santos que me curen porque ellos soy
una persona sana
si le recé mucho a san antonio para que
me mandara el amor de mi vida y si que
rece hasta lo ponía en penitencia cuando
no se me daban las cosas
cuando yo nací con espina bífida para
mis padres fue terrible enterarse de
esto
ningún padre ninguna madre está
preparado para recibir este tipo de
noticias
un día hablando con mi papá le pregunté
qué sintieron ellos cuando yo nací
y el con lágrimas en los ojos me dijo se
nos vino el mundo abajo porque no
sabíamos qué hacer ni adónde ir
sin embargo encontramos dónde ir juntos
a partir de ese momento fuimos haciendo
camino los tres siempre la parte como
hasta el día de hoy que estamos juntos
cuando yo era chica sobre mi
discapacidad con total naturalidad
llegaba una nena más una hija más una
hermana más
fui descubriendo que yo podía hacer todo
lo que quería pero había cosas que yo no
iba a poder hacerlas como los demás por
ejemplo
caminar sin apoyo
la primera vez que me paré con estos
aparatos fue cuando tenía 6 años no
saben la felicidad que yo tenía
ahora podía ir a donde yo quisiera
hasta en el aula
escribía de parada ya no iba a ser tan
fácil sentarme
me acuerdo que una tarde me caí en el
patio de la escuela una de las tantas
caídas que tuve lo largo de mi vida
y las maestras que estaban en ese lugar
en el recreo
se asustaron y bueno quisieron venir a
ayudarme a levantar y mi tía que era
docente ahí les dijo dejen la ella sabe
levantarse sola y así lo hice me levanté
cómo se levanta cualquier chico cuando
se cae pero a mi manera
la primera vez que yo me sentí diferente
fue mi adolescencia ahí descubrí que
había algo
descubrí que yo tenía una discapacidad
fue inconsciente de eso
lo notaba
en la mirada y en el trato de la gente
fue una etapa difícil
dura donde yo solamente me sentía segura
con mi familia en mi espacio
cuando terminó la secundaria yo tenía
que decidir qué hacer
tenía que proyectar mi vida
pero me preguntaba dónde iba a ir
que iba a ser y por mis miedos
no me podía ver en otro lugar que no sea
acá en sunchales
y es por eso que he decidido estudiar
para ser maestra
una carrera que me planteó desafíos me
dio oportunidades para crecer como
persona
fue una etapa difícil pero hermosa
pude fortalecer mi autoestima y fue
gracias a mis alumnos
gracias a ellos porque cuando yo entraba
al aula
para eso era la señora mí
ese amor me hizo fuerte
también me hicieron fuerte algunos
formadores pero por no creer en mí
poniendo en duda mi forma de manejarme
en el aula y mi capacidad organizativa
yo sé que ser docente no es soplar y
hacer botella no es fácil pero las
exigencias y las oportunidades tienen
que ser para todos
fue la aceptación de los chicos
y las barreras que yo tuve que enfrentar
en mi carrera las que me hicieron fuerte
y me dieron identidad
y con todo esto gracias a todo lo que
viví
puede obtener mi título
recibí y pude y empecé a dar clases
particulares
y también me inicié en el mundo del
trabajo
un mundo que me aterraba pero que yo
sabía que tenía que enfrentarlo
dándome
por lo que quería hacer y no por lo que
los otros me decían que era lo que
podría hacer
trabajé en un emprendimiento con
personas con discapacidad
también en la municipalidad y ahora
estoy trabajando en sancor seguros donde
no solamente yo me estoy adaptando sino
también mi entorno
[Música]
todavía hoy hay mucho prejuicio hacia
las personas con discapacidad porque
muchas veces son los demás los que te
hacen creer y sentir que la discapacidad
es un obstáculo cuando no lo es
a mi historia no la marcó la
discapacidad la marcaron las personas el
amor de mis padres de mis hermanos
de mi familia toda que con el alma de
mis amigos que están siempre me acompaña
de mis alumnos de mis compañeros de
trabajo y también la marcaron las
personas que decidieron ver mis piernas
antes que a mí
si viéramos a la persona primero y no a
su discapacidad hoy no tendríamos que
estar hablando de inclusión sino de
convivencia
particularmente a mí la palabra
inclusión no me gusta porque yo no
necesito incluirme en un lugar para
pertenecer
todos necesitamos de todos porque la
diversidad nos enriquece
y vamos cuando nos demos perdón cuando
nos demos cuenta de esto
todo va a cambiar
y respetaríamos así el lugar que cada
uno ocupa en este mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]